so when we took out loans for my school
my parents didn't have great credit and
I didn't have a line of credit so they
took out a plus loan and I'm the third
kid that went to school in our family so
they have Plus loans for all three of us
and then I have my separate subsidized
and unsubsidized loan under my name my
question is should I have the Parent
PLUS Loan transferred to my name and
refinance it to take the burden off of
my parents so I I just a new job I'm
going to make $23 an hour and then I
also um have like a side Nanny and gig
as just like a transportation to school
well it does know it it does not add any
value to move it to your name you can't
pay
it you don't make enough you're
struggling to pay your
27 am I missing something